في تفاصيل الموضوع قالت تركيا في وقت سابق
ان فصائل كرديه قتلت اثنين فيها هجمات
صاروخيه من شمال سوريا وذلك في تصعيد عبر
الحدود عقب هجمات جويه جنتها تركيا في
مطلع الاسبوع وهجوم بقنبله في اسطنبول قبل
اسبوع وشددت القوات المسلحه التركيه انها
كانت ترد على الهجوم
الامر الذي يتحدث عنه صراحه وزير الدفاع
التركي خلوصي اكار الذي اكد ان عمليه
القصف الجوي التي تشنها بلده في شمال شرق
سوريا وشمال العراق هي الاكبر والاشمل
والاكثر فعاليه ضد المسلحين هناك
المسلحون سيدفعون ثمن الوحشيه التي
اظهروها في الهجوم الاخير في منطقه
اسطنبول سنجعلهم يدفعون ثمن كل الجرائم
التي ارتكبوها اليوم وما قبلها وفقا لاخر
المعلومات التي تلقيناها وفي اعقاب غارتنا
الجويه المدعومه باسلحه ارضيه تم تحييد
184 مسلحا
وزيره الداخليه
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
العمليات العسكريه التي وقعت مطلع الاسبوع
جاءت ردا على هجوم بقنبله في اسطنبول او
دا بحياه سته اشخاص وحملت تركيا حزب
العمال الكردستاني مسؤوليه الهجوم الذي
نفع وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي يقودها
الاكراد والتي تضم وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه تورطهم بالتفجير الهجمات التركيه
دمرت 89 هدفا لحزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب التي تقول انقره انها
جناح لحزب العمال الكردستان
[موسيقى]